ding-ding-ding-ding-ding
welcome back to the Julian podcast this
week the special guest the devil oh
she's back in action
podcasts regular up a podcast regular
regular what and behind the scenes help
her runner of the podcast thank you for
the boss lady of the podcast thank you
for starting us out with that ding ding
you're welcome did you come up with it
by yourself
I always do what I'm told that's not
true episode is brought to you by
Squarespace guys build a beautiful
website with Squarespace it's so easy
they have the design templates the fonts
the tools to build a website online
store then we make it look exactly the
way you want it to look with Squarespace
amazing customer support right now go to
squarespace.com as quar resp a c-calm /
jenna julian and you can save 10% of
your first purchase of a website or
domain or try a free trial also guys me
Andy's keeping our BOTS comfortable for
what four years now
amazing underwear a three times softer
than cotton if you've never tried it you
don't know what you're missing I would
highly recommend you check it out get
their me undies they have all sorts of
different prints that is guilty over
there she's not wearing Mandy she's
naked go to me undies Emme UND IES comm
/ annejulien
save 15% of reverse pair free shipping
and 100% satisfaction guarantee what is
that noise so it is a special podcast
today with your sister guilty her
sisters I don't think she wants to do
that yes she does she does she wants a
suit just listening you can only imagine
dog heaven
leave me the dog come here I come I have
a very nice time the dog is in dog
heaven cuz there's like dog toys
everywhere that aren't wrecked like at
our house there's Jenna's there's
Jenna's
there's Julian there's pee cheese
there's marbles there's Sparky is being
held yeah she loves being she's what can
we tell you she's a wild she's a terrier
I'm a tissue that tear I call her the
terrierist yes wow that's that's
actually a funny name
I mean I think that's okay I'm okay with
it I accept it oh I'll accept it right
sips tea
cool shirt mom what shirt I don't know
about all that that's a lot what shirt
oh you can't see it I just see a
floating dink on how's it feel to be
back it feels really good this room is
like so different than the other I don't
think I've been in this house
you haven't recorded an episode here so
great so improved better much better
unbelievable plus crammed less crammed
less that's like you know just great
still the same mediocre content though
need yogur said oh yeah it's more marble
on the table I know he likes sleeping up
there so they have some cold brew coffee
here which I just I spit into okay you
know what no you didn't and don't know
you know let such that we're splitting
that no more pretending to spit in
people's drinks before we start a
recording with you Jenna put the coffee
in the center is that I'm putting this
energy Girija Jillian and Debby just
quietly grabs and goes I spit in it you
think you're so funny I am she is funny
give us a Debby update how you doing
how's everything going how's life life
is great yeah great yeah lovely yes I
live in Oregon and just nice people
there and I love it deer day increases
you're in the backyard yeah my little
apartment looks out over this beautiful
creek with deer in the backyard
and you know I live near my family up
there
Jonathas brother solace grandchildren
and nonsense and running around and
learning to walk and learning to talk
and all very exhausting learning to walk
is very exhausting lot of sass going on
five year old yeah bless you for living
near your son my brother everyone knows
who the better child is yeah I'm kidding
it's him
you can't corner her on the podcast well
not
I love how every couple of years you're
like oh I just found the stuff it was
just like as if you didn't move it
across the country to Oregon and like
you know have it in a very specific
place for all of these years I was
looking through this I didn't read any
of this but I was looking through this
and there's a book with like a leaf in
it you know like when you you learn
about trees and leaves so you like you
know tape a leaf it there's a perfectly
preserved leaf in here like you know
where this stuff is it's perfectly
preserved it's it's still a leaf it's an
organic Hey she brought it to you why
don't you say thank you thank you mama
anyways I was taking a bang on about
believe what the poor leaf alone way I
put on my Instagram story of that so my
aunt Diane your sister worked at NBC for
years and write and television
journalism in news yeah she worked at
NBC News so she did a piece on mr.
Rogers in the 90s and got this autograph
for me which I didn't know existed that
says to Janet from mr. Rogers 1990 as
well as Chuck Abner and mr. McFeely this
is so sweet it says Jana it's great
having you as a television friend to
remember people like you exactly as you
are your TV neighbor Chuck Abner that's
so nice yeah anyway in case you haven't
gathered yet we're just gonna be going
through some of Jenna's old memories and
notes and things that Debbie Machine has
brought from her home so we can all just
relive all the sass that Jenna had and
that Debbie had to deal with you just
brought all of this like haunted content
this is old content it's literally a
gold folder
with content that is gold inside of it
well so these look like more of the I'm
sorry mom letters oh yeah there's a
trunk full of them back in Oregon okay
I want that lie that's a lie shall we
get things started with some I'm sorry
mom letters well I think I should start
okay you know what's your W speak
because look you know you're I'm a mom I
happened to be a single mom but you know
I'm a mom I got these two kids and one
of them is full of sass full obsessed
wasn't me yeah her finger pointing at
you would argue at that point I'm
talking about right and so you know what
are you gonna do right I mean you can't
it can't really like a make her do stuff
you got to try to figure out a way to
contain her in some way
and so I don't even know how this wasn't
done to me but somehow I had this idea
which she talked about in the last
another podcast which was to when she
was out of hand to make her write a
letter to me about what she had done
wrong and apologizing and then in some
of them I think there are there should
be what my punishment should be so I
needed her to say what she did wrong
because you could never tell with her if
she knew what she did wrong she knew but
she would act like she didn't know so
she had so the letter had to be specific
and then if she had a punishment coming
I wanted her to think it up so that
that's the background of that and that's
why there are so many of them because
many of them didn't survive but many
were you calling me bad a lot I'm
calling you a lot I was bad a lot I was
a bad kid
you were a lot she said a lot called me
a bad kid and one said the word bad my
mom called me back so I'm bad right I
have to say in retrospect the fact that
she always wrote the letter when I asked
her to
yeah is really a tribute to her because
I figured one day she would just go I'm
not right no stinkin letter
no because I was like terrified to use
your terrifying [ __ ] up again that was
an intentional move on her part to
terrify you yeah but she talks about how
terrifying she was of me but I I just I
don't I don't see it I don't get it I
don't I don't think I was scary i well
for however like much I messed up we'll
see what I did according to to me in
these letters what I did wrong but like
I felt like I could have you know done a
lot of bad stuff there new bad kids you
know that we're doing bad [ __ ] like I
felt like I was doing okay I could have
been a bad kid but I was way too
terrified to like do like really bad
stuff you know right most of it revolves
around being disrespectful to [ __ ]
disrespect you disrespectful because
it's sass yeah
you know like mom no Vic I had a friend
whose little girl was so sassy oh my god
and she would sir mother would say go
upstairs and clean your room would she
go
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah that's really funny yeah no I
wasn't like I would talk back you know
like if my mom was like why didn't you
empty the dishwasher I'm like I don't
feel like it I was I was whatever you
know she's like that's not the issue I
asked you to do something and you didn't
do it and now you're talking back to me
I'm like what are you whatever mom and
it's not to your room go set up there
you write a letter and you come up with
you're on top having to do the dishes
well into it's like you know we're aware
that we're there alone with our mother
you know who's like worked all day and
she came home and one of us is starving
and she's like Amy dinner and she's like
what the [ __ ] do you want me to do like
I'm not Rachael Ray okay I'm Martha
Stewart can't make you something in five
seconds like relax till I feel Zahn
you know it's more like hyper aware that
like when you stress out your mother
your your single mother like now you now
you done [ __ ] up she would just yell
things like help me [ __ ] I can't even
[ __ ] empty the dishwasher [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] person I do remember you
being like you come up with your
punishment and me feeling like you know
really bad I'm like [ __ ] I'm like I
[ __ ] up and I would like a bright tone
of punishment like really suck like bad
she agreed to it and I'm stuck with it
and you know she just gave me a shovel
and you dug your own grave
three days later that's like you though
to a tee right like when you know you've
done something wrong you want to pay for
it yeah like there's no even if you get
away with it right
you're not gonna let yourself get away
with yeah you are you are the police
officer and the person you were arrested
you are both
was his letter all right it's more than
one this one looks like my handwriting
is like bigger and better so I'm
assuming I'm older
this says dear mom I'm sorry for over
sleeping this morning
I didn't mean to act irresponsibly it
was only the first time and I will try
it harder to wake up on time for school
by going to bed at at least 10 every
night so I'll be able to wake up in the
morning I am also sorry for being rude
to you last night and this afternoon for
this I think it would be fair to extend
to my dishwashing duty four more days
until Wednesday the 27th of next week I
promise to try harder to respect you
more and not to speak rudely to you in
the future thank you very much for
offering me contacts for Christmas but I
really think it should be taken into
consideration before then oh now I'm
asking ya every time I forget to bring
my glasses to school it strains my eyes
I'm becoming more and more dependent on
my glasses too what did this letter turn
into a proposal if I do the dishes but
mom can I please have my poor eyesight
fix glasses I'm becoming more dependent
my glasses to point where I need them
for simple things like reading bad music
please consider getting them for me
sooner I'm sorry about the living room
table I didn't mean to how did you ruin
the table it's just a pattern in my life
I tend to ruin tables you do you've
ruined like three tables since I've
known you
we ruined ruined especially from like
nail polish remover or like you know I'm
sure that acrylic nails like that one
downstairs right now has like acrylic
paint and your son has spread oil paint
all over that one too okay I said I'm
sorry about the living room table I
didn't mean to ruin it I put all the
nail stuff on the paper but Devon Devon
bumped it
out of the way to do his homework and
didn't realize it was on the table once
again I'm sorry for everything my dishes
will be extended until the 27th but in
the future it will be a week love Jenna
and by the way when you're when I when
it was your brother's turn and I would
say it's your turn to do the dishes he
would just say I'm just gonna throw them
away
I mean honestly a good strategy I would
say you need to learn to cook you learn
to clean what are you gonna do when you
leave home he goes I'm just gonna get
somebody else to do it
[Laughter]
imagine by getting actual like dishes
like ceramic and just chucking them into
the trash this one's just on an envelope
and there's nothing in the envelope but
this says this looks like my handwriting
is a little younger
it says dear mom I don't deserve des IR
ve I don't deserve to have any dessert
because of the way I acted to you this
morning
and Ed Zeb's and when I came from from
school and when I open oh my god it's a
lot better seven in a snotty way I just
want you to know I'm terribly sorry
I like the articulation of all the
things near the run-on sentence this is
what I want I would know how meant how
often you were rude and snotty and rude
at least that one didn't have like a
negotiation in it yeah and come up with
something I'm sorry for being snarky to
my brother which brings up a good point
can I have you guys I I don't recall
ever negotiating and in most of these
like well maybe you were just like in
the middle of writing and you something
came to you you thought of something
yeah well I'm here you know
communicating exactly by the way look I
haven't looked through these I don't
even know what's in there okay so it's
not like I have read through them or
anything this is - mom from ghin it did
I go through a time period where I like
to be called Jin
did you this this is very young
handwriting this is dear mom I'm sorry
for kicking you yelling saying things
that hurt h-he arty your feelings I'm
trying to figure out oh wait so this
won't happen classic right I'm trying
really hard to figure out wait up this
won't happen my leg won't kick here good
God
do you remember her kicking you oh god
no but I have a funny story about my
brother we're at Thanksgiving one year
and somebody kicked me under the table
and I looked at him and he goes I didn't
kick you we used to have this little
table and it was like you know it looks
like a diner table
they're like metal legs what would you
call that style I was like a 1958 no it
was like a it was like it was kitchen
tables looked like that okay they had
like a Formica top on it the rides were
metal and then the seats had that same
kind of pattern on the vinyl seats yeah
they were vinyl seats so it looked like
a little 50s table and it was like in a
little corner in our kitchen so all like
Devin and then my mom sat facing the
wall and then I sat on the end facing
another wall but it was like tucked into
the wall yeah so Debbie so like stretch
his leg out and kick me under the table
each other but like across my mom yeah
and I used to do that thing where it sit
in the chair and you know in the whole
like leg was just like giving in do that
to the chair there metal and it's not
like it's not like what its gonna break
or give it's kind of like mess it up man
it was fun yeah this is why we can't
have nice things
all right okay so this looks a little
older I had a purple pen this looks like
middle school this says dear mommy I'm
very very sorry
various underlined about last night I
got to do everything I wanted to do
yesterday and you were so nice to me and
then you asked me for one thing and I
didn't do it you can punish me however
you want and I will try my very hardest
to be nice to you and do everything you
ask me to I'm very sorry love Jenna PS
thanks th a and X so much for all my
clothes and presence for Alana I owe you
about $25 would you say this seems like
you helped me buy a present for someone
else so I owed you $25 negotiating the
$25 though that was also really nice of
you to give your mom permission upon
this year yeah so if I give you twenty
two or twenty reinforce you can see from
what she's reading
there was nothing was like rude like kid
stuff crying disrespectful right
basically stop shoot we knew if we never
did this one you never really did
anything wrong dear mom I'm sorry for
being rude to you today at the mall and
in the car you drove me everywhere I
wanted to go and let me do everything I
wanted to do all weekend and I'm sorry
I've had an attitude
I've just had a hard week a really hard
week and it's not very easy for me to be
cheerful because I didn't I didn't mean
to take it out on you thank you very
much though for buying me glasses and at
least letting me look at shirts thank
you for trying to be nice and happy
towards me love Jenna that's nice even
though you misbehave Sheila you window
shop that was the rule when we go to the
store it was like you asked for nothing
and I might buy you something but if you
go to the ground rule yeah yeah that's
why I would get good at like sneaking
things into the grocery cart at least
for groceries but ya couldn't ask for
things you just had to just do what
you're told and then maybe you could get
a treat
right cuz people are in the store and
their kids are like just like don't ever
start
that's smart actually yeah but you're
gonna start it at the beginning yeah do
that when they're like four oh yeah it
was like you know we go to the grocery
store and we're sitting there just like
oh my god maybe if we could we'll get
something we get to the checkout line
she buys us a pack of gum and we're
[ __ ] mental we did it oh my god we
did it
alright this says dear mom I'm really
sorry about how I acted towards you this
weekend I'm sincerely sorry about how
awful I was on your birthday and also
how I broke our agreement on the
sleepover I'm sorry that Libby and I
stayed downstairs watching liar liar'
longer than we were supposed to
legendary Foreman also how we stayed up
late and ate candy I I guess I was a
little grouchy this weekend because it
was the last few days of vacation but
thank God for you being so patient with
me and for driving me around places with
Caitlin on your birthday I'm sorry I was
really rude to you today on your
birthday and oh I'm awesome you were
rude to your mom on her birthday right
I'm also really sorry that I told you I
would finish my book on vacation and I
didn't and then you gave me extra time
to finish it thank you for being so
cooperative this weekend with me love
Jenna you see in the pattern here right
I'm seeing the pattern this looks like I
can never read your handwriting it's
like an ancient script that I cannot
understand but this is this looks like
an agreement between you and I and June
of 1997 where I wrote in the top it says
I promise not to whine and help around
the house more and then we we agree to
work together yeah I can't read this but
then you signed it and I signed it with
a smiley face this is an agreement of
what I'm not gonna do basically
is it like is it a legal binding
document yeah is it notarized maybe
let's see oh this is some this is a good
page yeah you both signed it at the
bottom there's no term length this might
still be in effect January 97 I think
it's still in effect
this this looks like I had just learned
a cursive writing and I was really
really giving it to you on this one it
was like I'm going right horizon that's
with the cursive dear mom I am sure we
can come to an agreement one idea I had
was every time you do something nice for
me I do something nice for you every
month we will try to squeeze in a mom
day where you have nothing to do and you
get to kick back and relax you get to
pick the date I just want you to know
how grateful I am to make it up to you I
will not watch TV for a week I sure hope
that this note pleases you since you are
taking me to the museum why don't you
think of something I can do for you in
return sincerely your very very very
sorry daughter Jenna I don't know what I
did that time it's a little glimpse a
little glimpse into the teenage hood I
wasn't a teenager in those right sorry
do you burn cursive were there a
teenager yes cursive when I was about 16
same time I drove a large emerging human
that is sitting here with us now mm-hmm
we love so much
okay don't be disrespectful as more
lessons don't be disrespectful that's
the lesson that is the lesson so do you
have more apology notes well let's see
what else is in here these are the a lot
of stories yeah right this time I tried
to bring what she yeah yeah I want to
hear some Jenna some Jenna what is it
fiction
yeah there's stories prose there's the
Frog I'm gonna read the frog the frog is
like its own whole little book the Frog
whoo
right children gather round we're gonna
read a story called the Frog by Jenna
what I love this Walt this little design
it looks like one of the templates that
Squarespace lets you pick from when
you're designing a website you want your
website to look as beautiful as the Frog
here by jenna mourey then you could go
to Squarespace comm slash Jenna Jillian
and choose from one of their beautiful
templates that look very similar to this
right now to build your website whether
it's for your small business or for a
hobby whatever it is Squarespace
makes building website incredibly easy
they have 24 hour a day 7 days a week
customer support they're on the horn
with you anytime you need help whether
it's a question about how to make
something look right on a tablet or how
to make your online shop look a certain
way or how to get control over the fonts
on this part of the page but not that
part of that you can customize every
little tiny thing on your website and
they make it incredibly easy to do so so
right now give it a shot you can try the
free trial when you go to Squarespace
comm or you can get 10% off the first
purchase of a website or domain you go
to at squarespace.com slash jana julian
building a website has never been easier
now do it with Squarespace you will you
will not regret it it's a really great
awesome platform also guys when you're
sitting there on your computer chair
building a website or standing there at
your standing desk treat your body right
with some me undies okay they have
amazing three times softer than cotton
micro modal fabric built underwear they
have new prints all the time really cool
artists collaborating with them they
have a awesome thing where you can get a
dual pair for you and your person if you
wanted to match underwears you can do
that they have a system where you can
each get the same type of pair in your
own size and and cut that you'd like
they also have bra let's they have socks
they have onesies that Jenna was wearing
all day yesterday and I didn't feel good
I'm in said goalie she's been sick so
I've only been wearing my me undies
onesie honestly when you're sick it's a
great time to pop on the old me undies
onesie when you're anything it's a good
time on the end he's one that is true
that is true yes they have all sorts of
loungewear and
I'm telling you like it's all exactly
the same softness it's just so
mind-blowing ly soft and you really have
to just try it out to believe it so if
you're keen go to me undies comm slash
annejulien get 15% off your first pair
free shipping and they guarantee your
satisfaction 100% so for whatever reason
you don't like it send it back I'll
refund you your full payment without
that's gonna happen though check it out
click the link below
all right onto the Frog now do you want
to read the Frog we that's the Frog
that's the problem
hey hey you got a do it like a story you
gotta get up on the mic okay
the Frog by jenna mourey copyright 1993
you copy wrote this hell yeah more
more-- and company and here's a way
towards this video gonna get strike
yeah for sure maureen copy that she that
she drew it's a green blob we're putting
our toes that's me so you are the frog
this book is dedicated to my mom and dad
already i jus you look how big your lips
are lipstick on a black dress your left
arm like those short and said you have
clubs for arms um compliment her don't
say she has clubs like bubbles coming
out of his shoulders what's actually
funny is that you've made your father's
clothes purple and turquoise no would he
would never wear anything no you didn't
wear those colors no that meant that man
was the color called blue yeah that's it
he's like I'm black once upon a time
there was a frog the frog was on a lily
pad Oh picture as you can tell I was
artistically gifted at a young age part
of the lily pad might be green screened
out here we're not sure what that's
gonna look like also the Frog my pee
green screen out so the whole story
might be a green screen
he was very nice it was a frog that was
never mean never mean and here's the
frog and the turtle you have you have it
you may I wrote you may and then ran out
of space so above it I wrote have it I
see he's giving a turtle or what looks
like a rock you may have it you may have
it I like how you said you may have it
that's correct very nice then the Frog
met a goose hi said the goose and here's
a good goose here's a thought bubble
with high point what what's your name my
name is frog mine is Samantha in the
thought bubble it says what it's a
speech bubble and it says what's your
name
so it's a little redundant with the
speech bubbles in the apex the goose and
the frog became friends it says it says
dress up but dress up and play or
something like that let's play or
something I'm a cake what is that man
playing math no it's like one of those
places that you go in a park that has
like the you know in upstate New York or
they have those like big castles oh yeah
that wouldn't play and a wooden play
structures the goose said look there is
a cool stream let's go have a drink and
here they are drinking and now it says
what I was I was excited to hear about
their adventures and here's the best
part about the oh no Julian has one of
these - that's with it
jenna mourey is six years old she likes
to do gymnastics she likes to play all
different kinds of sports Oh mine so
tame compared to yours six years what
was yours it was like I'm Julian six
years old I have a tool belt I'm gonna
go see Polly the movie oh my class has
an incubator
I was flexing for my class
[Laughter]
gosh they were really big on making
books and yeah so so you could get
published that was yeah I like that it's
like you stapled the edges right and
then in turn I mean in case I'm sure
they made those covers out of old
wallpaper mm-hmm
sorry here's a full book I like our life
we can you read books I'm like a little
kid oh yeah oh you leave me a book okay
so this is my mom also he's always say I
was obsessed with holding her hand and
making her every minute she was like you
either neat you were either like away
from me and can't be anywhere near me or
like Galland on top of me non-stop
somehow not surprising yes and then she
would like walk with me and like right
like I just can't even walk are you
walking in front of me I'm tripping over
you play with my elbows Guinness was
weird I mean it's really have you felt
her elbows dude is so fun that's hers no
it's mine
okay the potato cake look at that in the
very big box in a farmhouse cellar there
were lots of big fat potato Oh
one day the grandmother came down to get
some for her midday meal Wow okay that's
an advanced drawing I did not know I
could ever make oh look at this out of
the-- sure this is by me out of the
potato box the biggest potato called I
do not want to be eaten I am the king of
the potatoes but the grandmother saw the
big potato and said oh what a beautiful
potato I will make a big potato pancake
for me this isn't my book I didn't write
this she walked across the farmyard the
big potato jumped one two three out of
her basket and rolled through the yard
into the garden
I this isn't my book stop big fat potato
I will eat you
a hedgehog called stop big fat potato I
will eat you but the potato said
grandmother didn't get me and pick
prickle skin won't get me either he
rolled 1 2 3 into the woods a big bore
saw him and said stop big fat potato I
will eat you I can't draw like that this
isn't my book oh it is my book
she kept saying it's not her book right
so then the rabbits on the grant prickle
skin snuffle nose yeah but I think I
think this is that these are the two of
the pages here two children saw him and
said what a nice potato if we could get
it mother could make us a nice big fat
potato pancake the King stopped rolling
and the children picked him up and the
mother baked him into the most delicious
pancake ever so he goes through all that
trouble and then in the end he gets
turned into a pancake yeah life actually
a good okay I'll find us another
riveting story Wow I remember working
really hard on this one look that's a
lot of good artwork in there
oh we got some little short stories all
right sir 1996 I was 10 I think you
should read your own I wanna hear
generate some yeah I don't know I
haven't read these since I was 10
this says vibrato end for life Jenna
3:12 1996
11:10 a.m. don't get it twisted this
killer tofu spelled tof oh this is very
this sounds like it's influenced by the
television show Doug I was minding my
own business when it came explenation
park help it's mom's killer tofu
I was about to hurl mom made the worst
tofu now sit down and eat your dinner
said the victim eeehm right now
i sat down helplessly fine have it your
way as long as I don't have to eat that
horrifying tofu when I was done it crept
upstairs to give my cat bone head a
visit hi Boni there was a knock at the
door with no K and Ock come in I said no
answer come in I yelled a little louder
I went to the door no one was there
exclamation mark hmm
must have been my sister Eve just then
my x-men Wolverine telephone ring hello
no hits her hello I screamed
hysterically give me your life give me
your light unit it just says give me
your life are you gonna kill him that's
the end of the story
oh I even heard that sentence ever in my
life give me your life it's all we know
is that I had a Wolverine telephone so
that's true it's like an original cuts
are really necessary detail this one is
called the man that's it that's the
story the next day school was a jam
everyone seemed as if the world was
going to end what is the matter with you
people I asked my best friend Jimmy get
into the real world Matt did anyone ever
tell you that Michael Jordan is here I
seven ellipses hey where are you going
I didn't even stay to hear the rest Wow
Michael Jordan in our school I rested
this is very 90s I rush to the gym door
to take a peek at dawn dawn dawn Michael
Jordan when I looked in the gym door hey
that's not Michael Jordan that's just
some old man he tried to make a shot but
he fell down like he had a heart attack
or something I rushed in to help I ran
over and that's if there's anything I
could do to my surprise the old man had
the same voice as the man on the phone
oh these are the same story okay they're
just different chapters I guess so the
same person that said give me your life
it's the person that my school thought
was Michael Jordan wow what a twist
I feel fooled Oh next chapter real or
not
well you young gentlemen please excuse
us for one moment the man said timidly
the two men left with a puzzled look on
their faces listen kid I'm not gonna
tell you what DS I've have but all I can
tell you is I'm gonna find where you
live and take everything and own you and
your life then in a cloud of smoke just
disappeared oh he's gonna own you it's
gonna on me
so you're ten years old when you wrote
that yeah that's quite intense imagine
being a teacher and reading this and
being anything other than like good one
well what did it what like what was
there her teachers say to you oh I
didn't bring any other report cards but
yeah why wouldn't I want to know what
the teachers thought of Jenna they
basically thought she was cooperative
and nice and people like turned that was
true right I mean yeah you know no
teacher was ever disrespectful nothing
no not in school no only to me yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah oh I wasn't like an
[ __ ] but she'd be like do this thing
and I'd be like I don't wanna you know
like normal defiant kid things what's in
this I remember screaming it
just screaming it oh this one's so nice
though mom it's a broken heart and it
just says I'm sorry everywhere you know
I'm getting a little bit of a sarcastic
vibe from that that kind of feels like
you're making a joke of it somehow it
was kept so yeah yeah I'm sorry I'm
sorry this is a journal no one's
listening to this podcast anymore yeah
we've lost we've lost yeah but you know
what I am interested in is so I hope
what this does is it makes all these
people think of that are listening about
their own stories and with how they were
when they were little kids
yeah how much fun it was to write a
story or to you know draw pictures
mm-hmm yeah tell stories kids are the
best why don't we read this one called
chocolate dreams yeah
chocolate dreams who's the author jenna
mourey oh you okay this looks like an
advertisement but here we go are you in
desperate need of a deliciously sticky
smooth sweet and whipped chocolate
sundae of course but how do you make one
I'm here to tell you how the materials
you need to make this extraordinary
treat are Hershey's hot fudge vanilla
Ben and Jerry's ice cream
juicy cherries is this a recipe ready
whipped cream M&Ms chewy gummy bears
Jesus Christ rainbow and chocolate
sprinkles a bowl and a spoon you first
get all the materials you need then you
get them ready to be used then you fill
the bowl with two scoops of melting Ben
and Jerry's vanilla ice cream very
specific spray soft and fluffy whipped
cream all over the ice cream get out the
hot fudge and warm it in the microwave
till it's hot when the hot fudge is
ready drizzle it
this is a this is a recipe drizzle it
all over the whipped cream berry the ice
cream hot fudge and whipped cream with
tasty sprinkles crunchy M&Ms and chewy
gummy bears
I think we are learning about like
adjectives you know cuz they all have
adjectives now to crown your masterpiece
Oh plop as many juicy cherries very said
juicy cherries as you want ah what we're
done - one point now you need to make a
wonderfully chocolaty fluffy
scrumdiddlyumptious sundae you wrote
scrumdiddlyumptious your cue now for the
best part eat it and enjoy okay well now
I want an ice cream sundae
chocolate dreams more moon launch number
one good night sweetie
big day tomorrow first day back at
school my mom whispered softly good
night mommy I love you
I replied pretending to go to sleep my
mom left the room buckle up I said to my
stuffed animal pink monkey I scrunched
over my covers and began moon launch
number one oh yeah captain commando
finger you and lieutenant monkey must
get to the rocket ship take off as soon
screeched miss Camela one of the nurses
what she's just a nurse I don't know
okay alright right away i whistled too
far lieutenant monkey squeal I think
they squealed monkey school the loud
squeal as he came to my side we
approached the rocket ship and got in
beam me up Scotty beam me up Scotty
I mean blast me off I said calmly ai ai
ai report here applied over the radio
five four three two one liftoff the
computer echoed softly I watched the sky
get dark I saw the earth and watched the
universe seemed to you wrote suck the
window away but then they corrected it
to blast their sorry blast the earth
away BAM we hit something hard as I
looked out the window I didn't want to
know what it was lucky and I slipped out
of our slipped on our space suits and
pulled open the hatch
I screech as I flew out I landed on the
lifeless surface for phone to colored
lasers flew past us
of course commando thing this is
incredible of course commando thing er
the one and only me the master knew that
those lasers were aimed at us i swirled
around to see what the commotion was I
gasped as lieutenant monkey was being
held by ugly green aliens great googly
moogly you guys are aliens I screamed
of course we're aliens you mumbling
miniscule neener head oh did you expect
Santa Claus si la WS sniffled one of the
aliens who who are you where do you come
from I stumbled on my words
I looked down at my knees they were
shaking so much I couldn't stop them
return earthling or your life will be
eternally punished we stood there over
the boiling green acid tied back to back
on a thin plank walk now the alien
demanded as he whipped us mucky I
whispered press the emergency liftoff
button quick blub blub blub cling clang
liftoff
that's the sound effect that's the noise
it makes your spaceship just goes
liftoff we were in an instant built
rocket ship used only in emergencies as
we floated back to earth I heard my
mother's voice but in space I opened my
eyes Bobby Bobby
wake up you late for school my mom ran
out of ran out of the blank I don't know
it just says blank sat up and said the
monkey tonight we'll start moon launch
number two mmm thank you incredibly
creative I will say that was a quite a
ride felt I felt immersed ding did you
have a fascination with space I like
space I wasn't like a kid that was like
Oh mommy astronaut well I mean you love
Star Trek so I still love Star Trek I
don't know do you want to read any of
these mom I don't know why don't you
read this shows this picture oh oh you
like this one well you could read them
who's that is that you Jenna yeah that's
me I'm wearing overalls actually looks
like you thank you portrait well then
this was uh this is The Wizard of Oz and
the Wicked Witch in quotations of the
West with it this exercise I remember
was like take a classic fairy tale and
write it from another characters
perspective
wasn't this before like wicked and all
of that so I'm sure yeah so I did it
from the perspective of the Wicked Witch
oh I like that
but it was really fun like everyone's
came out really good they were really
fun to read yeah The Wizard of Oz and
the Wicked Witch of the West by jenna
mourey I is the first thing that it's
circled take the win right on with
[ __ ] sails teacher who are um I need
to identify who is telling this story
did you not see the copper or read the
title you're talking what the hell what
is this criticism along I stepped
quietly out of my nice little bedroom
and rubbed the sleep away from my eyes
as if she didn't [ __ ] a sinus like
Hello write it from another person I
like taking up the whole I was so mad
sounds like she was out to get you she's
jealous she's a hater okay just a
brand-new day had begun petting my
monkeys with care I planned my day I had
never originally planned to be an evil
witch to tell you the truth I wanted to
be good like Glinda the Good Witch it
was just in my blood
carried down from generation to
generation so I followed it all besides
it's not like I could pass as a normal
person with my green skin and crooked
nose but it was bad that I just was just
discriminated by the munchkins and good
witches that just makes me mad but you
learned how to deal with it I gazed into
my crystal ball to see how the land was
going and then suddenly there was a
great disturbance in everything a whole
cottage the whole thing just flew out of
the sky I was so appalled to see that
someone would just fly their house onto
my premises but that wasn't even the
worst part the house landed right on my
very own sister the Wicked Witch of the
East that was the last straw I clambered
to find my broomstick broomstick and
raced over as fast as I could
the nerve of the person who killed my
dear sister right my [ __ ] assistant
he's my [ __ ] sister's head wasn't
clambered yeah clamber clambered when I
got there I realized suddenly that the
house had belonged to a young girl she
was pretty too pretty
she had a wretched little dog that
yipped and ran about as if he owned the
place because I looked at the girl a
little more closely I realized she was
wearing my dead sisters ruby red
slippers first she kills her then she
steals her most prized prized possession
my ambition in life from that point on
had changed completely it was to kill
that girl
soon everyone grew to love this Dorothy
girl including the Tin Man interesting
and scarecrows I liked it I have had
personal problems with each of them
separately but those are all stories on
their own the point is together the five
of them made the ultimate enemy they
were all off to the Wizard of Oz as I
grew to learn each of them to gain
something from him I had to stop them I
tried everything but it was impossible
to stop them fire sleeping poppies I
even sent my own fleet of winged monkeys
to stop them it was just not fair that I
couldn't win I kept thinking of my
sister and all the good times we had
when she was alive so I gave up but
apparently they didn't they came to my
house not once but twice stole all the
possessions of mine like my broom in my
hat the very things that make me a witch
but now I was just steaming with fury
finally my guards caught them in the act
and looked them up and locked them up in
a dungeon to bring them to their death
slowly and painfully
I had rejoiced my trap at the end of
those horrible people tormenting me I
had set an hourglass to keep the time
before they would die in the dungeon
oh but second before the last grains of
sand slipped out through the tight
compact space of the hourglass the crazy
scarecrow went and got an axe and broke
down the door and saved them all it was
terrible just terrible all of my
beautiful plans have been ruined as the
chance to kill Dorothy had slipped
through my fingers
your beautiful murderous plans then as
they came after me they were armed with
a pail full of water the only way to
kill a witch and dumped it all over my
head sending my body into a mushy pile
steaming and bubbling as I melted
died is that they hadn't done enough
already so here I am on the Judgment Day
trying to convince you I'm not bad or
evil just misunderstood all I have to do
now is to fend myself in this document
of my last days hoping you'll understand
how it feels to be wrongfully accused
the whole story just got mixed up please
find me not guilty so I can find my way
up to heaven I know you make the right
choice thank you the Wicked Witch of the
West Wow clever very interesting that's
like an interesting assignment very
clever well especially two just to have
it set in this Court where you're being
judged Yeah right
yeah like purgatory or whatever we're
clever yeah yeah yeah that's oh well
done Jenna thank you so I hope everyone
goes back and finds their stories from
every level yeah they're fun listen to
them they're fun love yourself cuz
you're cool just the way you are even if
you had to write hundreds of apology
letters it's worth it it's worth it cuz
you probably deserve to write them I
think your brother used to write them
but they weren't anywhere near as
entertaining as yours and it were mine
better well because because there was
negotiation each one was a you know sort
of an interesting his punishments
probably were pretty standard whereas
she were you know always thinking up new
ways to punish her welcome to Jenna's
world it's constantly innovating her own
punishments I just think it's funny like
you I remember you getting to the point
where you couldn't really punish Devin
because he like early high school like
he didn't want to go anywhere like he
never left like he didn't go do anything
so it wasn't like she could be like
you're grown oh yeah you're grounded
does he'd be like I'm gonna be here
anyway like it got to the point where
she's like get out go go do something
call your friend but here's the phone go
call Damon what are you doing go play
basketball and get out he wouldn't get
out yeah well then then he turned he got
to be a sophomore a junior and then he
then he was great that he had all his
friends yeah everything changed but
yeah he like to hang around the house
and I'm like God I'm gonna leave him
here by himself I stayed at home because
he's just such a tall giant person well
I did tell him look you make it bigger
than me but you'll never be tougher than
me and I that is true I hold that to
this day he may be bigger than me but
you know never be tough squash him like
a bug Adam Oh get a machine
I'm telling grinding them up I'm telling
you the other thing about this one that
I was thinking of is I used to I used to
say to myself in to the people with this
one food clothing shelter in love and
just get the hell out of her way because
she just she was just a force of nature
that was wasn't forward well yeah I mean
well I'm trying to raise her as a child
so you trying to make sure she doesn't
get in trouble or hurt or something like
I mean this is this feels like a
full-time job to me oh yeah to make sure
that this force of nature does not you
know get injured yeah something bad
happened to her that's what all of this
was about was trying to make sure she
was stayed safe but that wasn't that
wasn't the case with her brother he
needed more stuff but you know I was
just trying to figure out how to not
squish her spirit right which was
fatally important to you but you know
firmly guide her and he's always always
good in school though like I was
terrified of Authority like I would
never talk back to teachers or like
that's something about you that I I'm
still you still that way and I rule I
respect it I do from time to time you
know I'm like a little bit like wow
that's a little overkill or like maybe
you don't need you know every single
flight she's reading the instruction
safety emergency manual and you know
always you know there's just no rule she
breaks out in the world which I respect
but Jenna Jenna sometimes you don't have
to be afraid of authority no but rules
are made to be broken right Debbie come
on just I have so much trouble not
breaking them that's right baby
break them rules baby I mean I want to
be
just respect the big my big fear is that
I'm gonna be disrespectful I don't want
to be disrespectful to anyone I don't
like yet but as far as you know just
doing something because somebody told me
to like mmm I'm not really feeling that
yeah I think I don't love rules but I
also I get why they're there and I my
thing isn't that like the rules don't
apply to me I'm more important it's like
I can gauge how it's supposed to be done
and I can make it happen right I know I
I can see the situation I know my goal
well my goal is I know the expectation
of how I'm supposed to act and I'm like
I can come up with a way to do this that
that will be safe trust me do you really
mean like I don't need to follow the
exact rules or recipe or whatever I know
how to do this just trust me
I got it but you don't really got it
right I mean you know ever sent got it
you just believe I Eve got I don't know
for a fact that I've got it I have to go
and try it and then in the middle I know
more of whether or not I got it or not
and then at the end it becomes apparent
mostly to other people but secondarily
to me if I actually had it it so she'll
see quicker than anyone if I had it or
not I think this is another good lesson
for all of us which is you don't have to
a hundred percent on know how to do
something to give it a go I like that
yeah yeah and if people are saying you
can't do that lets people say that to me
all the time you can't do that you can't
start a business you gave me I'm like
just you do it your way
yeah I understand homey doing whatever
[ __ ] I want in my life has anything to
do with you beats yeah and you know fake
it till you make it right like you know
figure it out as you go and you know if
like Jenna always says if you meet
someone and they say that they have
everything figured out they're just a
straight-up liar no absolutely lying or
they're so boring I mean if you really
really believe that then you would live
in such a bubble that it wouldn't your
life would stifling
I don't even know how you would be alive
freely I mean yeah I have a question
what's your favorite line I don't really
I didn't really watch vines yeah so
what's your favorite one what's your
favorite vine the the first one no no no
give us an impression of the any of them
any vine should be K I swear to God okay
you know what you need to write an
apology note for this right now that's
disrespectful we just melt [ __ ] I said I
didn't know when you just kept pushing
so I'm just gonna do what I feel like
thank you for listening to the podcast
thank you Thank You Debbie there's two
of the two of you still left listening
thank you thank you for being for
gracing us with your presence today I
love you guys thank you for all your
support everyone out there in here and
gosh you're the dick Pam is just
wonderful they're so wonderful they are
funny they're so funny yes we funnier
than us yeah yeah
what's than me I should say no I said
all of us all three of us all clever so
interesting so fun yourself right now
you guys have a wonderful week thank you
for listening thank you for watching
we'll be back and I will see in the next
one
[Music]
you
[Music]